they say breakfast is the most important
meal of the day most important meal of
the day so we better eat breakfast my
study from none other than Harvard
University states that men who regularly
skip breakfast have a 27 percent higher
risk of suffering a heart attack these
disease will lead to heart attacks and
strokes heart attacks and strokes
oh no I skip breakfast but I'm not
worried because now I know there's no
proof that skipping breakfast causes
heart attacks or any other problem that
Harvard study the authors actually
concluded it remains unknown whether
specific eating habits influence heart
disease risk there's no proof that
skipping breakfast is harmful in any way
it's been pushed it doesn't really hold
water nutritionist ruth kava points out
that all the claims about breakfast
being especially important are just
unproven that strokes and heart attack
news persists because people who skip
breakfast have more health problems but
that's partly because breakfast skippers
are more likely to smoke and eat
unhealthy foods
there is just no proof that skipping
breakfast itself causes problems I've
skipped breakfast for years that's fine
really fine it works for you you're not
fat we're all different yeah we're all
different we have to do what's
comfortable for us another myth about
breakfast is that skipping it may make
you fat people who skip breakfast were
more likely to be the big weight gainers
over time the government claimed that
just nine years ago saying not eating
breakfast has been associated with
excess body weight but that's not true
either according to a new analysis they
looked at a number of different studies
and they did not find that eating
breakfast helped people lose weight so
how did some researchers and our
government get it so wrong partly cuz
eating habits are hard to study you
can't follow test subjects for years
controlling what they eat most studies
are based on what people say they ate
and people forget or lie also we may
have been suckered by studies funded by
cereal makers
of the 15 studies involving children
mentioned by the government 5 lists
funding from General Mills or Killah
mm-hmm yeah well they're the ones that
are interested in having their product
sold in fairness not all cereal
companies spin the results one study
funded by Quaker Oats found eating
breakfast did not help people lose
weight this study was unfavorable to
Quaker Oats but Quaker Oats said let's
publish it good for Quaker Oats
but let's not count on companies to tell
us the truth about nutrition study found
people who didn't eat breakfast could
lose weight by starting to eat breakfast
Kellogg's touted this on their cereal
boxes don't get your nutrition education
from cereal boxes are you okay hi but
what if instead of a cereal box it's
America's first lady on Sesame Street
I'm very tired didn't have no energy oh
I think I know what would help
what's Secret Service air force what no
Grover a healthy breakfast now there is
data that shows children who do not have
decent nutrition during the course of
the day have been shown to do better if
they get some food into them in the
morning that's where that comes from
it's phone it's appropriate
unfortunately I'm Sesame Street Michelle
Obama doesn't just say children she says
everyone this isn't just for first
ladies everyone should have a healthy
breakfast not me and much of the media
push nonsense like claims that if you
eat the right breakfast you are going to
end up boosting your metabolism losing
the belly fat restoring gut health
restoring gut health there is so much
bad information out there the current
consensus is eat breakfast if you're
hungry eat breakfast if you're hungry if
not eat a little later